Dr Brooks wasn't there a calendar change
in history how can we know which is the
Sabbath you know I get this question
more than once and it always amuses me a
little bit and now here's why the music
is made people who've been keeping
Sunday all of their lives never feel
mixed up but the minute they hear the
truth they get mixed up
I don't understand it
and they don't understand it
you can't mix up Sabbath without mixing
up Sunday would you say Amen out there
if one's mixed up the other is mixed up
but people aren't really mixed up
if I told you that I'm going to give you
a thousand dollars on the seventh day of
the week you'd be there is that right
yeah that's not your problem now was
there a calendar of change yes there was
we live under what we call the Gregorian
calendar Pope Gregory was given credit
for affecting this change in the year
1582 and here's what happened Thursday
was the 4th of October and Friday was
the 15th
10 days were taken out to make an
adjustment in time but Thursday was
still followed by Friday and Friday was
still followed by the Sabbath the change
did not update the weekly cycle not only
that it cannot but the Bible tells us in
Ecclesiastes chapter 3 verses 14 and 15.
I know that whatever God do it it shall
be forever nothing can be put to it nor
anything take it from it and God doeth
it that men should fear before him that
which hath been is now that which is to
be have already been and God requireth
that which is past Ecclesiastes 3 14-15
thank you next Please Mr Brooks suppose
the days are all mixed up after all
these centuries then how do we know
which day is the Sabbath well there's
that question again
mixed up and beloved
I've already answered it really we're
not mixed up until we hear the truth and
then we look for excuses part of this is
understandable folk have been doing a
certain thing so long and then they hear
the truth you know what happened to me
I was a Methodist it happened to me and
my family
oh dear ones God doesn't send the truth
to embarrass you or to offend you
but to Enlighten you
and you some of you have to learn it
just like I had to learn it
but it's not going to change for us amen
ever since
God made the Sabbath men have really
known what it was or whatsoever God do
it it shall be forever now suppose you
say well what about before history was
written I showed you the other night
that Adam knew Methuselah fought 243
years Adam could tell Methuselah
Methuselah knew Shem for a hundred years
and Shem was Noah's boy
and Methuselah died the year of the
flood but Shem had heard it from
Methuselah for a hundred years and she
knew Abraham
so in just three generations all of that
truth was passed along but it wasn't
written down the first writer of History
was not Herodotus as they tell you in
history it was Moses and he was inspired
to rate it and when Moses was leading
the children of Israel out of Egypt
the Bible says they were in a Wilderness
and they couldn't buy food so God rained
down Manna he ran down what he rained it
down six days a week and God said gather
enough on the sixth day to last on the
Sabbath and if you if you do that it'll
stay fresh
but if something leaves a rascal tried
to gather enough on Tuesday to last all
day Wednesday the Bible said words got
in it and it stank
so what did God do for 40 years
he re-established the rhythm of the
weekly cycle and the Jews have never
left it since nor have the Gentiles we
know which day is the Sabbath if you
don't read your calendar reach Almanac
reach a dictionary read the encyclopedia
read the Bible next please Pastor here's
a person that wants to know how can so
many people be wrong about the Sabbath
well I've answered that so many times
please let it come through this time if
people went to the Bible and the Bible
only every believer would be keeping the
seventh day because that's the only one
in here now if that's clear please say
Amen
let me give you another answer for over
1200 years and we're going to preach
about this on Saturday night the subject
is the truth about a wonderful lie and
it will be clear
I'm so glad truth is clear you don't
have to be confused unless you want to
be would you say Amen how many here
don't want to be confused raise your
hand okay I'm talking to the right crowd
Pastor now if you're here Saturday night
you will never Wonder again
but during the Dark Ages there was a
great apostasy in the church
and the people were taught tradition
instead of scripture tradition the
decisions of the church rather than
scripture and the world got into a bad
habit
you'd do anything for 1200 years you get
into a habit
and when the Reformation came they only
cast off certain things and clung to
others and that is the answer to your
question Nick please Dr Brooks who was
Michael was he Jesus if so is Jesus a
created angel
the Bible refers to him as Michael the
Archangel Michael the Archangel in both
Testaments in the New Testament
Revelation chapter 12 there was war in
heaven and Mike Dale fought and the
dragon thought there was a decisive
battle fought in heaven between Mike
Gale the Archangel and the dragon which
is Satan according to verse 9 of that
same chapter I was preaching in Egypt
and there were some folk who said this
man believes that Christ was created no
I don't
I believe Christ was the creator I
believe that he was God from eternity
past and will be God for eternity future
amen
well what about this Mike Yale first of
all before Christ became incarnate that
means in the flesh it Bethlehem before
he was born and became the son of man he
manifested himself in the presence of an
Angel but it was still Christ it was
Christ who met Joshua with a drawn sword
it was Christ who went before the
children of Israel
but since he had not taken on flesh it
was difficult for them to understand
that it was actually Christ he was
called the angel of the Lord he was
called the Lord of hosts Etc Mike Gail
I was accused of saying that in Egypt
and I presented some rather important
and substantive answers Mike KL Mike KL
is a compound word
L is a contraction of Elohim which is
the name of God if you say Bethel Bethel
it means House of God
as Samuel L and Joel always that El on
the end of a word as a suffix indicates
the name of God Elohim
and so Mike KL in the original means one
who is like God would you say amen
that's what Mike L means but he's called
not an angel but Archangel what does Ark
mean Ark means ruler or King if you say
Monarch that means one king huh
if you say use it in other terms the ark
represents ruler or one who is supreme
so what the word means is one who is as
God who is king or leader of the Angels
that's what Mike gal the Archangel means
Christ is is God and he is the ruler of
angels next please
Dr Brooks who are Guardian Angels who
are they what are they and where are
they
well the first of all the invisible
Spirits angels are in this room right
now I wouldn't want to be in here if
they were not
the Bible tells us in Hebrews 1 14 that
the angels are ministering Spirits sent
forth to minister unto them that shall
be Heirs of salvation
God has Myriad Angels multiplied
Millions one place it speaks of Ten
Thousand Times Ten Thousand that's a
hundred million right there and then it
says in thousands of thousands plenty of
them and they are involved in the work
of Salvation along with a godhead these
angels are ministering Spirits they save
your life when you don't even know it
needs saving
these angels are around you protecting
you the Bible says the angels of the
Lord encamped round about them that fear
Him I believe that I remember one night
a gang of Ruffians in a large city where
I was doing evangelism in a big tent
came and told the young man in charge of
my tent we are coming tonight burn this
thing down
well they didn't come
and several days later one of them came
along and he had a very friendly
attitude
and he came up to talk to the man the
young man that I had there and and I
don't know why the young man asked but
he said I thought you fellas would come
back to burn the tip down he said we did
come by but you had all those men
standing around the tent
ladies and gentlemen the angels of the
Lord in Campground about them that fear
Him
not only that but Jesus said in Matthew
18 10 be careful how you treat these
little ones for their Angels always
behold the face of the father meaning
that the guardian angel even of a child
reports to the father how that child is
being treated and led and taught or not
taught
Angels invisible spirits that attend
God's people thank God for them next
please Pastor is it true that what you
don't know won't hurt you
yeah I told you that somebody said to me
once I wish I hadn't heard the truth
then I wouldn't be responsible oh yes
you would
the Bible says in one place acts 17 30
says at the times of this ignorance God
Winks when you don't know God weeks but
you better not hide behind that because
Hosea 4 6 says my people are destroyed
for lack of knowledge but it doesn't
stop there it says because thou Hast
rejected knowledge
and that's the key
there are some who reject knowledge it
isn't that they've never known or could
not know it's that God sends truth and
sends them an invitation you know what I
believe with all my heart I believe that
when my workers pass out these hand
bills every time they hand out one the
holy spirit is there saying to the
person you ought to come and hear this
if I didn't believe that I wouldn't do
this work I believe it
and people resist truth you tell folk
lies they enjoy it
I think people like to be fooled if I
were up here fool in them you couldn't
get them in the church be so many of
them not only that you know what I could
do I really believe this I really
believe this I believe that I could come
in before a large congregation
and I could tell them that untruth and
fool them and I could take up offerings
and give some of it back and in a little
while I'd be a millionaire
Jewish is happening all the time
did you hear what I said
but when you tell them the truth I don't
know what it is in us that resists the
truth
they don't want to hear the truth Thy
word is truth would you say Amen
next please
this is a sincere secret for truth
saying is it true what you don't know
won't hurt you I buried a man once who
had a spot on his lungs and didn't know
it
this is a sincere Seeker for truth I
believe Pastor in their writing the
Bible says that Jesus went to hell and
preached to the spirits there please
explain did this really happen well
always make sure that you know what the
Bible says
it doesn't say that says he went and
spoke to Spirits in prison
let me read one of them for you they had
two or three references that people
refer to you see all of this is based on
tradition and because the Bible doesn't
matter tradition even the Christians are
not quoted correctly so I'm going to
First Peter chapter 3 and I'm going no
first Peter 4 I think is the one I want
to read first Peter 4 and verse 6. stand
the Bible says and for this cause was
the Gospel preached also to them that
are dead that they might be judged
according to men in the flesh but live
according to God in the spirit and some
think Christ was preaching the gospel to
dead people that is what it means it
means he preached to people who were
alive and who were dead now when my
daddy was living I gave him a suit
amongst other things and I could say
today I gave a suit to a man who is dead
doesn't mean I gave it to him after he
died
I gave it to him while he was living and
he's simply dead now that's all the text
means and the other one is found in
First Peter 3 and you should begin
around verse 18. for Christ also hath
once suffered for sins that just for the
unjust that he might bring us to God
being put to death in the flesh but
quickened by the Spirit by the spirit
Christ was quickened or Made Alive by
the Spirit by which also he went and
preached unto Spirits in prison not in
hell in prison which sometimes were
disobedient when Once the long-suffering
of God waited in the days of Noah while
the art was of preparing wherein few
that his eight Souls were saved by water
ladies and gentlemen Christ preached the
people in the prison House of sin
through the Spirit by that spirit that
quickened him from the dead and it was
Noah who did the preaching but the Holy
Spirit made it clear to the minds of the
people who abound and imprisoned by sin
and that's all it says and all it means
next Please Mr evangelist I've heard of
people who say folks strain at a gnat
and swallow a Campbell
is that in the Bible
I am glad you want to know the Bible is
blamed for a lot of things that it does
not say
but this expression swallowing a gnat
and gagging at a camel is found in
Matthew 23 and verse 24 it is in the
Bible next please
the Bible say God hardened Pharaoh's
heart then God destroyed him please
comment
many Bible commentators will tell you
that God is often blamed for what he
does not
expressly forbid if he allows a thing
then he's given credit for it there's
one place where it says God sent a lying
Spirit now you know God doesn't do that
what it meant was he did not stop it and
therefore he was credited for it and
this question wants to know why did God
Harden Pharaoh's heart well let me tell
you God loved pharaoh and when he said
to Moses go tell him let my people go
Moses said well who shall I tell him
said it God said tell him I am said it I
am God God is sending him a message he
has an opportunity to believe God he has
an opportunity to obey God but because
of his rebellion and his unbelief
he came to a point where his heart was
hardened I remember a way of explaining
this that I perhaps used scores of years
ago you can take some wax and some wet
clay and put them both in the Sun
one will get hard while the other was
melt
one will harden the other will soften
it's the same Sun the problem is not in
the Sun
the problem is in the substance that is
placed inside
whenever you hear God's word and you
decide not to do it you are literally
hardening your own heart and you can
come to the place where you cannot see
you cannot believe you cannot understand
next please Pastor what does God say
about healing preachers
I left some names off this because we
don't want to call names
but if you will read well before that
let me tell you something and I hope
you'll understand exactly what I'm
saying God gave gifts to his church and
he didn't give everybody the same gifts
the gift of healing was a gift given to
some the Bible says not to everybody and
God never gave gifts to men that they
might profit thereby and build up huge
personal treasuries if you understand
that say Amen it is not only sacrilege
it's blasphemy for men to become rich
because of what God does now God Is A
Healer I have been personally healed I
was over in Africa and I got sick now I
want to tell you when those things hit
you in these tropical countries you are
sick it felt like Knives have been
thrust into me and I looked at my watch
and I had just about 23 minutes no I'm
sorry I'm thinking of something else 40
minutes 40 minutes before I would be
picked up and carried to a pavilion to
preach
and I didn't have access to anybody to
pray for me except myself and oh it's
good to know how to pray
you got to have a speaking acquaintance
with the Lord for yourself you might
need to preacher sometimes you can't
find it would you say Amen
and I remember talking to the Lord and I
told him he understood how sick I was
and what my responsibility was that
night thousands were waiting on me and I
said now Lord I have never missed the
night because of sickness I preach with
the flu I preach with temperature but
I've never missed a night now I said to
him I'm not just interested in keeping a
record going I want to do your will now
if you want me to go and preach tonight
you've got to do something now and just
like you hit a light switch all of it
ended
and I went down there in the name of
Jesus and preached I've been healed I
believe in it but everybody doesn't get
healed oh
everybody doesn't get healed of you but
I said and I'd like to prove it the
Bible says that Jesus healed Peter's uh
my wife's mother but there was a servant
of God who was a preacher an evangelist
who went everywhere preaching Christ and
he said I had a thorn in the flesh
and I asked God to remove it three times
do you know God actually told him not to
pray about it anymore
God did not heal him who was that man of
course it was Paul and Paul being
enlightened said I rather therefore
glory in my infirmity
that the Excellence said might be of
Christ and not of me he said lest I be
exalted above meijah God left that thorn
in the flesh there if you want to read
it go to Second Corinthians chapter 12
and start if you will around seven to
nine and you'll read it Paul didn't get
healed
God does it as he Wills and some folk
would never live right if they hadn't
been saved
some never get on their knees till the
burden is heavy on their shoulders some
never look up to Jesus until they're
flatter their backs thus suffering
becomes Redemptive
it becomes a Ministry
and then there are others whose Faith
reaches out and God heals them
but all this show that's put on for
money is not of God next please
Pastor Brooks he was a young person who
wants to know when should people start
dating goes on to say nothing sexual
just dating
this is relative
and there are many answers that could be
given one is when you're old enough and
mature enough
and you don't need to rush it your time
will come nobody's trying to keep you
away from it it will come but I want to
tell you something the longer you wait
the better you'll be
I remember when my daughter was growing
up she never asked and then I'm glad she
didn't I didn't have to deal with that
that was a group of about 12 of them
that went everywhere together one day I
sent her a cod with a bunch of bananas
on the front and I said a banana only
gets in trouble when it leaves the bunch
so it's actually better to put it off
because there are certain pressures that
come with dating realistically your
bodies are young and operating at Peak
efficiency you are not ready for certain
pressures so put it off until you're old
enough and smart enough to deal with it
now one of the answers when you're old
enough and mature enough another is when
your parents say so
let them have that parental role and
eventually the time will come and if you
have kept yourself pure you will thank
God in your marriage we'll be off to a
good start
be worth it next please
pastor this was a little long in Matthew
5 19 where it says shall be one of the
least Commandments shall teach men so
shall be called the least in Heaven will
he be in heaven call the least or we'll
leave you on Earth all right let's let's
go to school the Bible says in First
John 3 4 whosoever committeth sin
transgresseth also the law for sin is
the transgression of law what is sin
breaking God's law now another text says
the wages of sin is
now a person wants to know because Jesus
said whoever breaks one and teaches
others is called least in the Kingdom of
Heaven they want to know does that mean
he'll get there only to be called these
oh no no no no no you're not going up
there with sin Let Me Tell You Jesus and
angels and the father discuss us
job wasn't in heaven and God said to the
devil have you considered my servant job
they had been talking about job up in
heaven amen
well if a man does and teaches God's
Commandments the Bible says Matthew 5
17-19 all of that the Bible says he is
called great in the Kingdom of Heaven
but if he teaches men not to obey God
when the father and the son and the
angels mention him up there he's the
least thing that walks the ACT
but he's on Earth
you can believe that next please
Pastor do you believe we should pray to
Saints
well no I do not believe that and the
Bible does not teach that we are not to
pray to any human being first Timothy
chapter
2 and verse 5. there is one God
and one mediator between God and man
now that's explicit language you don't
have to stumble over that it doesn't
require interpretation
this is English my mother done and most
of you speak English
the and those who don't are having it
interpreted listen the Bible says there
is one God and one mediator how many
one mediator between God and Men the man
Christ Jesus amen
so you don't have to pray to another
human being
the Bible says rather in Hebrews 4 16
come boldly to the throne of grace
you'll find Mercy to help in time of
need when you need a savior there is a
savior living at the Throne of God who
hears and answers prayer you don't have
to go through any other mediator there
is one God one mediator even Christ
Jesus
please explain to us Matthew 19 24 is it
impossible for a rich man to be saved
well of course not
that text says it's easier for a camel
to go through a needle's eye than for a
rich man to be saved and some conclude
therefore that it must be impossible for
a rich man to be saved well let me tell
you many of the Bible characters who
love God were fabulously rich
Abraham was
and so was Isaac and so was Jacob they
were very very rich
Joseph of Arimathea was rich
Nicodemus was rich I read a book by The
Man by the name of Babson an economist
he said Nicodemus Ben gorion could
support the entire city of Jerusalem 10
years out of his own pocket and he
estimated it would take a billion
dollars a year so Mr Nicodemus was a
billionaire many times over
so it's not a sin to be rich
then what does this text mean easier for
Camel to go through a needle's eye one
of the simplest explanations is this the
city of Jerusalem had main gates
well the Caravans went through the
camels the horses the Chariots
but there were also some small
pedestrian gates
they were narrow and small and were
called needles eyes
now if a man came with a camel leading
ordinarily he'd go through one of the
main gates
but was it possible for a camel to get
through a pedestrian gate called a
needle's eye the answer frankly is yes
in order to get him through first thing
he had to do was unload him
then get him on his knees
and if you unloaded that Rascal and got
him on his knees he could squeeze
through
a rich man can make it if he will unload
and give a part of his Blessing to the
poor and to the work of God unload and
get on his knees he can be saved it's
going to be plenty of them up there